こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん”ロケット”って知ってますか
まあロケットって聞くとこう…なんかすごい…
俺は…怖いイメージを持つんすよ
戦の道具じゃないですか
こう戦が起きるとこう…
ビュンビュンッビュンッ
ふぇっふぇっ
ビュンビュンッ
ふぇっ
…あーーー！
ロケットだーーー！！！
逃げろーーーーー！！！！！
みたいな感じのー
戦における危ないものランキング
5本の指に入るぐらい
危険なものだと思うんですよ、ロケットって。
もしそれがですよ！
もしそれが
どう思いますか？
嫌でしょうね
そうです、嫌なんです
ロケットを家に撃ち込まれるのってみんな嫌だと思うんですけども
はじめアミューズメントパークにロケットが撃ち込まれることはあるんですけども(？)
多分実際撃ち込まれると
あの、みんなびっくりするんですよ
というわけで今日は
をしようと思います
まあいっても撃ち込めないんですけどね☆
まあ撃ち込めないんで
今回ですね
事前にロケットを撃ち込まれたような状況を作ります
というわけでこちら
フッｗ
ちょっとｗｗ
ど、どう…見せればいいか難しいんですけどｗ
はい
です
僕思ったんすよ
ロケット撃ち込まれると
うち壁厚いんで
途中で止まるんすよ
壁に刺さって止まるんですよ
なんでこの状況！
この状況を再現します
なので壁にこのロケットの先っぽだけぶっさしておけば
まあロケット刺さったんじゃねえかっていう見え方がすると思うんですよ
部屋から見ると。
見てくださいこのデティール！
特注で作って頂きました…！
壁ぶち抜いて入ってきたんで
ちょっと傷ついてる感じがちゃんとでてますね
ほら先っぽも
もう完全にこれ刺さってたら絶対ロケットでしょどうみても！
はい、という感じのこのロケットの先っぽを
壁にぶち込みます
入口周辺の壁にこれをぶち込んどいてぇ
ターゲットが上ってきてぇ
部屋の中見るとぉ
目の前にロケットがぶち刺さっている。
はたしてロケットが刺さっている部屋を見て
ターゲットは何を思って何を喋るのか
見ていこうと思います
ではロケットを壁に撃ち込んでいきましょう
ハッ！！
[ドリルの音]
はい！というわけでですね！今ー
ただロケットが刺さっててもあれなんで
壁に穴っぽいのを業者さんに作って頂いております
ロケットがこう…ぶっ刺さると壁が割れるんで
その穴開いて割れてる感をここには出させてもらってます
で、ひび割れたここに
これをこう刺して
完成でございます
しばしお待ちを！
は)すみませんよろしくお願いします
業者さん)お願いします…(小声)
ありがとうございました
業者さんにお手伝いして頂き
取り付けて頂きました
こちらですwww
www
まってディテールがすごいんですよ
本当にまじでロケットぶっ刺さったら多分こんな感じなんでしょうね
なんかすごいのが
ただ壁から出てきてるんじゃなくて
こう…刺さって壁がバラバラってなったところまでちゃんと再現されてるんですよ、ここ。
すごいです、芸が細かすぎて…
本当にすごい
はい、というわけで今から仕掛けていくわけなんですけども
ターゲット目線からすると…
何もないですか？
こうやって来てぇ…
ん゛～～～～～～～
ってなる予定です。
はい、というわけで
私の家は基本何でもありなので
ちょっとありそうでないようなギリギリラインを攻めて
部屋に入ってきたらミサイルが刺さっているドッキリ
をやっていこうと思います
早速、ターゲットを呼んでいきたいと思います
ではいきましょう
は)バロリィィィ！！！
バ)はいはいっ
は)ちょ、ちょ早く来てー！来て来て！
は)ちょっと来て来て来て！
は)早く早く早く！！
バ)え、どこすか、上？
は)上上！上上！
バ)上？
は)早く早く早く！
は)早く！早く！
バ)はいっ
バ)えー！なに！え、ちょ！？×３
は)あっはっはっはっはっはｗｗｗｗｗ
は)壁にロケット...ぶっ刺さるドッキリでした
バ)いやｗ普通にびっくりしましたｗｗ
は)ビビるんだねちゃんとー
バ)あ、僕ビビらないと思ってました？ｗ
は)ちょっとビビらないと思ったけどー
は)これで多分、みんなビビることが分かりました
は)では、次のターゲットにいってみましょう
は)けんすけぇ？
け)はいはいはい
は)ちょ、早く早く早く！！
は)早く！！！
け)はいはいはい
は)早くっ
け)はいはいはい…
け)うぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉ！！！
は)はっはっはｗｗｗ
け)え！！！すごい！！！
は)ちょっと時間差あるのは何だ↑
け)ここしか見てないから
け)ここ見えてなかった
は)ｗｗｗ
は)死角なのな、ここぉ
は)というわけで、壁からロケットが飛び出るドッキリでしたー
は)どうでしたぁ？
は)ともたかぁ？
と)はいぃ
は)ちょっと早く！ちょっとやばい、緊急事態！
と)はいはいはい
は)早く、やばい
は)早く早く！　と)はいはいはいはいはい
は)早く早く早く！　と)はいはいはいはい
と)うぅうわぁぁぁぁ
は)はっはっはっはっは↑www
と)あ…っぶなw
と)ミサイル…すか？w
と)あははははw
は)すげーともたかが珍しくびっくりしてたw
と)びっくりしたもう完全に
と)ラリアット入りそうになったっす今
は)もし他の人にミサイル撃ち込まれたらドッキリでした
と)なるほどw
は)だいちくんごめん！ちょっと、いい？
だ)ういっ
は)ごめんちょっと、急いで急いで
だ)あーはいはいはい　は)ちょっと緊急事態
だ)なになになに
だ)えっ！？
だ)え、本物？これ。
は・だ)wwwwww
は)シールまで気付くの初ですねぇ
は)ありがとうございました　だ)ありがとうございましたw
は)以上ですw
は)やふへゐくーん？
や)すみません！
は)ちょっと上！上大丈夫すか？
や)はい！
は)すみませんちょっと！緊急事態でダッシュでお願いします！
は)すみませんすみません、お願いします
や)なんすかなんすか
や)ぶらぁぁらそうるっっ！！！(？)
や)え！？！？！？！？
や)えっへっへっへあっはっはっはっはっはwww